the following table describes the
relationship between the number of
servings of spaghetti bolognese I don't
know if I'm pronouncing that our
Bolognese and the number of tomatoes
needed to prepare them test the ratios
for equivalence and determine whether
the relationship is proportional well
you have a proportional relationship
between the number of servings in the
number of tomatoes is if the ratio of
the number of servings to the number of
tomatoes is always the same or if the
ratio of the number of tomatoes to the
number of servings is always the same so
let's just think about the ratio of the
number of tomatoes to the number of
servings so it's 10 - 6 which is the
same thing as 5 2 3 so here the ratio is
5 to 3 it's 15 to 9 if you divide both
of these by 3 you get 5 - 3 so it's the
same ratio 15 - 25 if you divide both of
these by 5 you get 5 - 3
so based on this data it looks like the
ratio between the number of tomatoes and
the number of servings is always
constant so yes this relationship is
proportional